-Our first guest tonight
is a legendary actor
you know from his work in films
"The Thomas Crown Affair,"
the "Mamma Mia!" movies,
"Mrs. Doubtfire,"
and as James Bond.
He stars in "Black Adam,"
which premieres in theaters
and IMAX October 21st.
Let's take a look.
-A wise man once told me
a bad plan is better
than no plan at all.
-That was before
we had a very bad plan.
-Let it go.
I'd rather be fighting with him
than against him.
-What's the helmet telling you?
Somebody's gonna die.
Who is it, Atom Smasher?
It's Atom Smasher.
-Surprisingly no.
-Is it me?
-When it's time for you and I
to say goodbye, you'll know.
-Please welcome to the show
Pierce Brosnan, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That was very kind of you.
I feel like not enough
of our guests
do a little dance
right at the end.
-Oh, I just saw it
on the TV one night.
And I thought I'd do it now.
-Very natural. Very good.
-Very natural.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
-We worked together before
but never met.
-This is true --
Sarah Jessica Parker, yourself.
-We were in a film called
"I Don't Know How She Does It."
And you were the second lead.
And then I was on the end
where they had to
make the arrow different --
from a different angle.
-Yeah.
I remember that.
It was winter here.
It was a beautiful time.
-It was nice.
It was working in New York City.
Always a pleasure.
-I enjoy it.
I always love New York.
It's so good to be back here.
-It's great to be back here.
This is -- Did you know
this world, the Black Adam --
You play Doctor Fate
in the film.
These are famous
DC Comic characters,
maybe not the most famous,
though.
-My sons told me about them.
And so I did know
about Black Adam.
I did know about Doctor Fate.
And, you know, it was
the last thing I expected
but quietly desired
and wondered whether
I would ever be asked
to be in one of these movies.
And it just came out
of left field.
-So you finally found your way
into a superhero movie.
Very nicely done.
-I did, yeah, really.
Well, slow and steady.
Tonight's a big night.
And it's a great film.
It's a beast of a film.
It's a feast of a film.
And it was amazing
being with Dwayne
and watching him do his thing.
I've watched this man rise
to the beautiful prominence
that he has now as an actor.
And the cast were wonderful.
Aldis Hodge and Quintessa
and Noah.
We game a kind of
little quartet,
you know, the Justice Society.
-One of the very important
things about Doctor Fate,
which I'm happy to report
they got right, is the helmet,
which is --
-Oh, yes.
-They did a beautiful job.
Were you involved at all
in the forging of the steel
to make the helmet or --
-No, but Jaume Collet-Serra,
who's the director,
who's a really fantastic
director, brilliant man,
and greatest admiration
for him, again,
because this was a beast
of a film, he said,
"Do you want to have a hand in
creating this beautiful helmet?"
And I said, "Sure."
And we talked about it.
And sent me photographs.
I said,
"That looks like a bucket."
You know, it was just --
And something sleek and elegant.
And so, you know, in the movie,
you see me
carrying this helmet around.
And that was the aesthetic,
beautiful one.
And then they had another one
which really was like a bucket.
So it fit on my head.
-It was -- Oh, I see.
So there's the prop you carry
and then -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause it's too sleek
to actually fit
on a human head, right?
-[ Laughs ]
-I will say, it would have
been very funny,
for all your wonderful acting
and all the seriousness
of your dialogue,
if then you would just
put a full bucket
on your head at the end.
-Exactly.
Oh, I'm sure someone will do it.
You'll see it at some point.
-Were you aware --
Growing up in Ireland,
what were the superheroes
you were aware of
back in the days of your youth?
-Oh, well, I grew up in a small
country town, Southern Ireland.
And there were two cinemas,
the Palace, the Lyric.
And I grew up on a kind of diet
of cowboy movies.
-Sure.
-My mother, bless her,
would send me, from London,
comic books,
the "Eagle" comic books.
Um, I guess Batman was my hero.
So, you know, as a little boy
in Ireland, Christian Brothers,
we'd put our raincoats
around our neck
and swing from the bicycle shed,
you know.
-A very -- Well, an upgrade on
costume, then, this time, yeah.
-Very much so.
-Even a bucket would have been
an upgrade over that.
-True.
-You have been --
You've been an artist for almost
as long as you've been an actor.
And you actually have
a gallery show coming up.
This is some of your
beautiful artwork here.
-Thank you for showing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I'm wondering --
It's --
I guess it's a little similar
in that when you make a film,
you know, you do it
and then a great deal of time
later, people get to judge it.
For a gallery show,
it's the same.
Do you get nervous
before people come in
to see one of your shows?
-Yes.
I mean, this has on the cards
for a few years now.
I've been painting since '87.
-Wow.
-I started as
a trainee commercial artist
and discovered acting and became
an actor, thank heavens.
These paintings --
Anthony Bourdain.
Broke my heart the morning
I heard the news.
And I went and painted it
straightaway.
The other one
is called "Night Marcher."
We live out there in Hawaii,
so it has a certain influence.
And, you know, I've just accrued
so many paintings,
and my wife, Keely, said,
"You got to show.
You have to show."
-Is that her way of being like,
"You got to get them
out of the house"?
-Got to get them
out of the house.
Too much storage, money.
Our life is in storage.
So May 13th, we're gonna
have a show in L.A.
I'll -- On May 16th, I turn 70.
-Alright.
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get in under the wire.
-So I -- We talked a little bit
backstage.
This was -- I did not realize.
This is one of my favorite
films, "The Long Good Friday."
-It's a great movie.
It's a great movie.
Holds up incredibly well.
You're in it.
I did not realize
it was your first film,
as evidenced by the fact
you appear on the poster
less than I appeared on
"I Don't Know How She Does It."
So...
-Yeah.
-That is not saying a lot
about your billing at the time.
There's a wonderful --
It's the final scene
in the film.
I don't want to
give anything away.
But it's you
and the great Bob Hoskins.
-That's right.
-He gets in the back seat
of a car.
You turn around with a gun.
It's an incredibly dramatic
final scene.
-Yeah.
-He was --
It was like you and I on
"I Don't Know How She Does It."
You never met him.
-Never saw the man.
I was out of drama school
maybe a year.
My director said, "You've got
a movie, 'Long Good Friday.'
You're playing
IRA Man Number One."
I went, "Okay. Great.
I'm in the movies.
I'm off to the races."
And they just said --
They didn't send me the script.
They said, "Show up
at Tooting Bec swimming pool
6:00 tomorrow morning."
I went and I was
IRA Man Number One.
-Yeah.
Got to do a murder right away.
-Got to kill him --
pick a guy up
and then stab him in the shower.
[ Laughter ]
Usual fare.
But it's a -- Yes.
I mean, the soundtrack
on this movie --
-It's one of the most iconic.
It's amazing.
I watched the scene today,
and every time you watch
anything from the film,
you remember exactly
how haunting that score is.
-Yeah, and the end of the movie,
they --
we got to the Savoy Hotel, and I
really wanted to drive the car,
because I knew
what the scene was now,
that we had the guy, we had
Bob Hoskins, number-one guy.
And I thought, "I really want
to drive the car.
I just so want to drive the car.
Gonna look like Steve McQueen.
It's gonna be so cool."
And the director,
John Mackenzie, said,
"Right,
you're in the front seat.
In the front.
Get down there now."
And I thought, "Oh [bleep]
This is no good.
This is really boring."
And we drove down the Strand,
and John Mackenzie,
the director, God bless him,
he drove.
Phil Meheux was in the back
with the camera.
And he said, "Action."
And he said, "Just come up
and point the gun."
And Bob Hoskins wasn't there.
He was just, you know,
a dot on the camera.
-I mean, you certainly would
never watch it and not think --
As actors, you both obviously
do an incredible job
making me believe you were there
at the same time.
-Well, it's Bob Hoskins.
Bob Hoskins
just owns that scene.
And I just happened
to be part of that scene.
-Yeah, I guess probably still,
like,
that's less of a special effect
than we're gonna see
in "Black Adam."
-"Black Adam" is huge.
It's a colossal piece.
-I think it speaks to exactly
how long you've been
in this business
that you go from IRA Man
Number One to Doctor Fate.
Not a bad ride.
-Stay in the ring
as long as you can.
Thanks a million.
-Pierce Brosnan, everybody.
"Black Adam" -- theaters
and IMAX October 21st.
We'll be right back
with Sharon Horgan.